[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy hump day
oh
dude's going to jail
you stole nuclear secrets from foreign
countries what in the actual [ __ ]
would a foreign former president need
with nuclear secrets of a foreign
country in his goddamn destroyer why
what what what could possibly
a former president use and how does he
think these are his documents at this
point
what what what the [ __ ] does he want to
have foreign
countries
nuclear secrets
think about it for a second i mean
there's only a handful of possibilities
here
this didn't have anything to do with him
this isn't pictures of him this isn't
his documents it's not
it's not a trophy
he was gonna sell them or use them as
blackmail
or use them as payment
i mean
how else are you gonna shake this
we need to politicize the [ __ ] out of
this marco rubio this morning on
fox and friends says the narrative
the narrative is because there's leaks
at the doj there's not leaks at the doj
you dumb [ __ ]
trump and his legal team has forced the
doj to talk about this
has forced them to talk about this
what in the [ __ ] are you talking about
and
i can only imagine because dude has
lost his [ __ ] mind
i don't know if you guys have a true
social account but holy [ __ ] is it
entertaining the last couple days
dudes up up today
posting
about his weight
i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ] you
he's still this morning
[ __ ] has new clear secrets of
foreign countries
out in the open within arms distance a
margaery taylor green kyle rittenhouse
and lauren bobert
think about that for a second
think about that let's put put that in a
[ __ ] nutshell
but [ __ ] is still focused
on how ronnie jackson lied about his
medical records
still focused on it and the reason why
is because apparently his medical
records were in these boxes
which is not surprising this [ __ ]
slob that's one thing he's really upset
about that america knows he's a [ __ ]
slob here
that he doesn't unpack his [ __ ]
because i mean that's why they have a
lot of this stuff is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
was still in the boxes a year and a half
later he never took him out
i mean besides the [ __ ] he stole out of
the top secret boulders
and and did something with i don't know
if he destroyed him he ate them and
ketchup flushed them down the toilet
sold them to saudis or russians
i don't [ __ ] i don't know how we
supposed to [ __ ] know at this point
you would think if there was plenty of
leaks that they would be leaking that
sort of [ __ ]
now they're not leaking that sort of
[ __ ]
they're leaking the stuff that trump
wants them to leak i i want i want this
unredacted no no reject it please reject
it don't say don't tell the american
people my crimes
and and
people out there are thinking that this
is uh gathering up support
gathering up support for trump get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
a [ __ ] treasonous thief
he's a traitor
and anyone who still supports him and
runs around going maga make america
great again
is a [ __ ] traitor too
you are a [ __ ] traitor
you're not patriotic you're you're not
american
you're a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] and we
all know it and i think people getting
tired of this nonsense have to happen
and [ __ ] capitulate
to these cry baby snowflake fascists
shut the [ __ ] up already no one wants
your goddamn authoritarianism
we don't want it
we don't want it we don't give a [ __ ]
if you want him to be your jesus or
something we don't give a [ __ ]
we don't want to hear about it anymore
all we want to do is watch him get
prosecuted for crimes
and die in prison that's what we want
cuz he's never gonna shut the [ __ ] up oh
he'll never shut the [ __ ] up
after this election when he's finally
indicted on some of these federal
charges possibly these state charges in
new york and georgia he's not going to
shut the [ __ ] up
it's going to take years to get to trial
to some for some of these cases i mean
if you if you haven't if you haven't
noticed what he likes to do he likes to
delay he'll pay all kinds of [ __ ]
money
to delay even if it hurts his case he'll
[ __ ] do it
what he doesn't understand is this is a
criminal case this isn't a civil case
so he's gonna delay delay delay as much
as he can
it's his mo and he'll be able to do it
especially in the federal court he'll be
able to delay for a long time because he
won't be able to hold counsel
he won't pay him he won't listen to him
they'll [ __ ] quit he'll [ __ ] fire
him he'll hire new council
they'll push back this they'll push back
that because now the council has to be
up to speed
it's going to be hard for him to hire
council anyways
i mean they're gonna have to have some
sort of [ __ ]
security clearance here
on this case to see the discovery
because the discovery is top secret
[ __ ] documents
what in the actual [ __ ] this [ __ ]
treasonous piece of garbage
speaking of treasonous pieces of garbage
steve bannon is going to turn himself in
on thursday to the state of new york
i wish i had a sound effect for party
ah what a dumb [ __ ]
they thought pardons were going to keep
them keep themselves from getting
prosecuted you are a bunch of dumb sons
of [ __ ]
you can't just keep criming and you
can't have committed crime in a state
either
normally normally a pardon
is for one federal crime
one
or one that of several that you've been
convicted on and been jailed for a while
like rod bagoya [ __ ] he pardoned rod
begoyevich you remember that
which i'm not saying rod begoy that
should or shouldn't have got a pardon
but that is generally how a pardon works
well he didn't pardon me commuted his
sentence but you know what i mean
he's in prison he's been serving time
and they they
they give him the mulligan
rather be a partner commuting a sentence
that's generally how it works
they don't pardon [ __ ]
preemptively
normally
just don't it's not normally how the
process works but when you have a
[ __ ] criminal when you have a [ __ ]
criminal who's willing to steal
foreign
foreign governments top secret nuclear
secrets
to i don't know trade to another country
so you can get a building there maybe so
you can fly there and
and and be safe from prosecution i don't
know i don't know
i don't know
i'm just snowballing here i mean i
if you
if you want to know what the hell you're
going to do with foreign countries top
secret nuclear
secrets i mean just think about it it's
like okay
if i were to steal when i after i was
the president and i and i got voted out
of office by 8 million votes and then i
tried to commit a coup
right tried to commit a coup
to remain in power so they wouldn't
prosecute me
but i know i'm i'm out of office now we
tried the insurrection thing we tried
the supreme court thing we tried the
fake elector thing we tried to get the
vice president to crown me king
hell we even tried to go down and in a
county down in georgia and chain and
[ __ ] with the machine so we could blame
it on the machines mike lindell's still
talking about this today by the way
whoosh this [ __ ] guy
but none of that worked so what am i
gonna do i've only got a few days left
in office
my
my money guy here his name is cash my
money guy here tells me and maybe just
maybe there's some top secret documents
that i can use
to maybe force
a country
whose leader i love
i'm his girlfriend we haven't broke up
yet
and maybe just maybe putin will give me
the ability to build a tower in his
country and i can i can seek refuge
there
and maybe maybe just maybe i could sell
some secret i don't know i'm just i'm
again i'm snowballing trying to figure
out what mindset
is [ __ ] crooked criminal
this [ __ ] lunatic is in because if
you read his post last night jesus
christ this guy is freaking the [ __ ] out
i don't know if he
if he just popped some pills or what but
the word salad was
yeah it was it was astounding it was
amazing actually
it was amazing i thought it was some
sort of artificial intelligence that was
like turned on the social media just to
tweet for him our post for him he's not
tweeting over there truth and whatever
the [ __ ] it's called
over on fraud social ain't gonna last
very long
you might want to get your screenshots
while you still can on true social
because it's not gonna be there very
long [ __ ] going broke
they're gonna have to turn that son of a
[ __ ] off
and you'll be able to go back to the
wayback machine i'm sure
to the internet archive
um but
hell [ __ ] these [ __ ] idiots
these [ __ ] idiots and again you got
you know
marco rubio this morning peter navarro
talking more about this crazy [ __ ]
um
it's you get the sydney pal story
and then the other story we have this
morning of a bunch of trees and as [ __ ]
is the oath keepers which honestly is
not a story
i mean
it's not a breaking news story
it's not
we've been reporting on it for months
i interviewed
tasha adams and dakota vaughn adams
stewart rhodes estranged son and wife
and they told you in their interview in
february and i think i'm gonna pull that
clip and we'll post it up on youtube and
maybe we'll even put it on twitter
of tasha and dakota describing yeah they
were [ __ ] recruiting police officers
military elected officials you goddamn
right veterans you goddamn right they
were recruiting those people they've
been stewart rhodes had been recruiting
those folks
for decades
and you also know if you're a viewer of
the show and really if you want you can
just subscribe to the youtube channel
i've got a playlist of the oath keepers
interviews that i've done with dakota
and tasha
just go to the playlist tab and you can
go to the oath keepers um
playlist and you can watch those
interviews so just subscribe while
you're on the youtube channel and go
watch those those interview but i think
i'm going to pull a clip
so it's easier digestible you know easy
to digest
like a minute minute and a half
something like that of them explaining
oh well yeah subscribe
oops accidentally hit that button but
here's the thing
if you
if
you go back and look at those interviews
tasha and dakota adams said from the
very beginning for a long time
that these people were always recruiting
law enforcement elected officials
veterans
to these para militia groups and the
reason why stewart rhodes wanted to do
that and and he even tried in the
beginning
of the oath keepers
all the way up to really right before
donald trump was elected
he tried to keep white supremacists out
of the oath keepers believe it or not i
mean there was white supremacists in the
oath keepers they would just scrub their
social media accounts so they couldn't
be out in the open
they couldn't be out underneath the rock
but see that was really difficult when
donald trump came on the scene
because all these white supremacists
crawled out underneath their rocks
so it was hard to recruit people who
weren't overtly white supremacists and
saying racist bigoted [ __ ] on their
social media
so stuart had to kind of go along and
get along
but they always were recruiting these
folks
and the other thing that i think
this is missing that this that isn't
news that we broke here again we've been
talking about this for [ __ ] six
months here
eight seven months eight months here on
the tony michaels podcast that's why you
listen every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and the books of face
because we've been we've been talking
about the oath keepers and telling the
truth for many many months
that a lot of these a lot of these
chapters don't have anything to do with
stewart rhodes oath keepers
it's just the branding that they kept
because stuart stewart was off the
[ __ ] chain and a lot of these
chapters in these states and these
counties knew he was off the chain
so they were kind of fracturing anyways
and the reason why they were fracturing
is because the exact reason why stewart
rhodes tried all those years to make
sure overt white supremacists
weren't visibly in his group because he
knew that the cop police elected
officials couldn't be in a group with a
bunch of white supremacists
and that's who he wanted to recruit and
the reason why stewart rose wanted to
recruit law enforcement
former military veterans current
military
uh elected officials is to give his
organization
some bona fit days right he wanted to be
bona fide
he wanted to seem legitimate we're not
just a para military group we're not
we're not a we're not a militia
we're something different we're people
who have taken an oath that's where the
oath keepers come from it's people who
have already taken an oath whether it be
through law enforcement elected official
veteran uh active military what whatever
whatever oath
that they would take
and that's who he recruited but again
they tried to keep the overt white
supremacist
at bay in their organization for a long
time until they couldn't anymore because
then they couldn't recruit
and stuart because he's a box um
i mean
i'm kind of paraphrasing there but if
you listen to the interview with tasha
and dakota they kind of tell you that
stuart wasn't very organized as far as
keeping people
he had a revolving door because he would
just piss people off
and they would get frustrated with him
and they would move on so he was
constantly having to redo his membership
and redo his
the the leadership structure of the oath
keepers
which only led to worse and worse and
worse leadership
and less
and less and less capable leadership
which led to whites over white
supremacists taking over that
organization like like kelly surreal
we watched the last week she was
indicted
and apparently they gave her pre-trial
release
with a lot of conditions
the federal judge gave conditions to
kelly surreal for her pre-trial release
because apparently she was forging
documents or some [ __ ] or obstructing
with forging documents which it that
she's really [ __ ] she's gonna have to
start turning on these [ __ ]
which um i think only gives you more
evidence that the department of justice
is moving in the direction the upward
direction
of the oath keepers with possibly roger
stone
and mike flynn and others that were
involved in organizing with the oath
keepers on january 6.
that's the upward mobility
because what they do what the what the
feds do
is they try to get someone who's a
quote-unquote smaller fish
to tell on the bigger fish and how they
do that is they pressure them
and maybe they've been pressuring kelly
surreal for over a year now
and she wouldn't break so then they
indicted her and you usually usually
that gets someone's attention
when you federally indict someone on
four criminal charges and they get kind
of they go oh what what
oh well i'll pay attention now
i have to pay attention they're you're
not going to ignore the feds when they
indict you
and they got all the time in the world
like all the time and the money is
behind the doj
once they indict you there's no [ __ ]
it could take 20 years to [ __ ]
convict you they don't give a [ __ ]
because
their clocks their the clock stops the
minute they ignite you
i mean this this idea that that donald
trump can delay through federal charges
is really [ __ ] dumb he's been
committing he's been committing federal
felonies just in the last week
just in the last week there's these
[ __ ] missing documents out of these
folders are somewhere they're [ __ ]
somewhere folks
and if you think that this [ __ ]
has stopped committing crime
oh it's like saying steve bannon in the
[ __ ] box
that's scabby [ __ ]
speaking of justice
steve bannon is going to turn himself in
tomorrow
to the state of new york because the
state of new york is going to indict him
on the we build the wall or whatever the
[ __ ] the
the fraudulent fund where he he
he raised funds from trump supporters
who were probably still giving to trump
and still getting grifted like a
[ __ ] and stole their money
he was on federal charges you remember
him and a few others and they're still
gonna get federally prosecuted but he
was pardoned of these charges for this
case so he can't be federally prosecuted
and he was pardoned by um oh what's that
guy's name
the cheeto guy what's the guy's name who
uh
who indicted his accomplice to overturn
the the election
oh yeah trump
he pardoned steve bannon for these
charges
the problem is
the problem that steve bannon has now on
thursday
is that
donald trump was the president of the
united states
he had the jurisdiction authority to
pardon
on a federal level
see
steve bannon
is about to be arraigned in a state
court the state of new york where
trump's pardoned has
no jurisdiction then i mean it's more
worthless than toilet paper that it
would have donald trump's face printed
on it it really is
[ __ ] worthless
so
steve bannon is going to join
alan weisselberg here in the state of
new york being under federal charges
arraigned at a federal charge excuse me
criminal charges
under the state criminal statutes
for this scam this fraud that he that he
that he
defrauded trump supporters out of their
money people that are probably still
giving money to trump and his campaign
and the save america pack and all the
nonsense all the fascist groups that
they're still giving to they're probably
still giving money to the rnc so the rnc
is paying his legal bills in the state
of new york because the rnc has said
we're not paying legal bills on
mar-a-lago and that is clear have you
noticed that that that the rnc is not
paying any money for his attorneys for
this seek top-secret document said he
sold this case where he's gonna go to
the [ __ ] federal pen
for committing espionage
that they are not they are not
paying his bills legal bills on that
case it's obvious because his attorneys
in that case are [ __ ] stupid holy
[ __ ] you couldn't you you could find a
better goddamn attorney in a crackerjack
box
but i digress let's go back to new york
so steve bannon is gonna be arraigned
tomorrow on these charges
and he he posts somewhere on some stupid
[ __ ] traitor website that he's gonna
fight to the end and he's not gonna stop
fighting blah blah blah yeah can you
shmackity yeah okay steve okay okay
buddy fight till the end go to trial get
20 years in a state prison you dumb
[ __ ]
you are a stupid bastard and i i i would
imagine
i would imagine that this case
over the contempt case because he also
he also is being held on uh
he's about to go get sentenced
in his federal case for contempt of
congress so he'll serve jail time for
that so what will happen is here's what
will happen
if the judge decides to detain him which
that judge should [ __ ] detain him
give him no [ __ ] bail [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] that tree treasonous piece of [ __ ]
we do not need that guy on the streets
[ __ ] him
if they detain bannon for his extended
period of time he'll serve a jail he'll
be in jail so the clock will start
ticking on his state sentence
right
if they detain him
and and and they'll give him that time
but what will happen is if he's
sentenced by a federal court he'll and
they give him jail time for the fed
he'll go to a federal prison
because the feds don't [ __ ] around with
the state like if they got you detained
at a state and they don't even give a
[ __ ] you got a trial they don't give a
[ __ ]
they will lock your ass up in a federal
prison the feds hold way more weight
over the state
so they'll lock him up in a federal
prison while he's waiting trial
for his new york case
if you follow me there so steve bannon
is not going to be in front of a
microphone for very much longer i mean
that's the hope they better these
[ __ ] judges need to pull their heads
out of their ass and realize
that hey we need to we need to show this
country that the bench still has [ __ ]
credence here because the the judge down
in florida the [ __ ] the judge cannon
this this ninja poop federal society
bought and paid for trump judge
this [ __ ] idiot they need to take her
off the bench whatever they got to do i
don't care if it takes six months two
years whatever they gotta do she does
not belong on the bench it is more clear
now than ever that a lot of these trump
judges that he [ __ ] nominated and
mitch mcconnell rammed down our goddamn
throat are [ __ ] worthless
not only not only are they [ __ ]
sycophants for these [ __ ] fascists
but they don't know their hit from their
ass
they have no clue she doesn't even
[ __ ] know that the dni and doj is
part of the executive branch doesn't
[ __ ] know it are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me
it's like tommy tuberville became a
federal judge doesn't even know what
[ __ ] branches of government we got
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
she doesn't know that the dni
and doj are part of the executive branch
no clue what has no idea you can't claim
executive privilege from the executive
branch
the executive privilege isn't because of
donald trump
it's because of the executive part of
the government
you stupid [ __ ]
this is why these people are going to
fail and going to keep failing
it's because they don't even understand
our system of government they don't get
it and the reason why is because they
[ __ ] hate it they disdain democracy
they [ __ ] hate democracy and the
reason why is because you get a voice
they don't want you to have a voice they
don't want you to tell
tell them that they can't tell you what
to do they want to be able to tell you
what to do and when to do it and tell
you you're stupid
for not wanting to do it their way
so it's time now is the time to lean
into democracy
lean into that [ __ ] all the way
because on the other side of this 2022
election this midterm
that we're that we're just
weeks away from
on the other side of that midterm
democracy is waiting for you
it's waiting there all you have to do is
take it that's all you have to do
and it's not just about voting i know we
talk about this a lot engaging in our
[ __ ] ballot and it doesn't just mean
marking the ballot
you have to engage in your democracy you
have to be talking to your family your
friends your colleagues your your fellow
church parishioners
their way of life is at stake
and they're showing you they're telling
you out loud and i show them telling you
out loud every [ __ ] day right
here on the tony michaels podcast
believe it is so important for you to
know what they want to do with your
rights what they want to do with your
country your community your family it is
[ __ ] vitally important that you know
so that you can go tell other people of
what you know what these [ __ ]
want to take away from you because they
don't want to give you freedom they want
to take it away
and they showed their hand with
roe they showed their hand with row
and not only did they show their hand
with row boy they really leaned into
autocracy
after row was overturned every single
one of these [ __ ] fascist state
legislators
said i'll take away all the rights
even ron desantis
the [ __ ] florida fascist
says
take away books take away math
it starts starts getting rid of elected
officials
down in the state of florida
stick around we're going to go to the
shitless roundup for all the new
listeners we got a lot of new listeners
today for all the new listeners out
there
we go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting on facebook
don't forget to come over to the youtube
page and subscribe to the youtube page
you're not going to want to miss a
single single video you're not going to
want to miss a single piece of content
also follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod you can also download
every single episode
don't forget to download these episodes
don't just look at my beautiful face
listen to my beautiful voice on apple
spotify google wherever you download
your podcast leave us a review and
subscribe there don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
oh nuclear nuclear nuclear nuclear oh my
god
[Music]
oh jesus so the guy and his attorneys go
out and they're like oh yeah i thought
there was nuclear
information that he stole
i meant there was nuclear stuff that he
stole huh huh what about that
it's all it's all imaginary it's all
[ __ ] and then this morning we've uh
well last night we find out
yeah there was definitely nuclear
information
in in the boxes and it wasn't just our
nuclear information apparently it was
the nuclear secrets of a foreign
government holy actual [ __ ] crime crime
crime crime crime like literally
just boxes and boxes of crime here
that's what we find out that's what we
know
and it's only going to get worse from
here this is like
i can only imagine i mean it is this is
trump right so i mean like this is the
tip of the [ __ ] iceberg
this is a tip of the iceberg
this isn't we're not even close
we're not even close
to knowing the entire truth
and exactly what happened here
but they're freaking out republicans are
freaking out especially the ones that he
apparently has extortion on them in
those boxes i don't know i mean i'm just
guessing here i'm just [ __ ] guessing
i would imagine
that that [ __ ] would not just
steal
top secret
foreign government nuclear secrets but
he would probably steal blackmail on
other republicans
you know that way when they find the
[ __ ] documents and try to charge them
with espionage they would
you know sycophant for him on fox news
or newsmax or wherever
so we got a lot of tape to show you
on them telling you hey we're gonna
support a treasonous trader
we're manga republicans so we're
definitely going to support a trader
yeah so let's do this we ever to all the
new listeners out there we surf the
tweety tweets and trinity trends every
single weekday and today is no exception
we got a lot of video to show you gabe
sanchez my co-host is going to be
joining me soon so let's do this
let's go to the shitless roundup surf
all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show you have
entered the shitless roundup where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of the day we go through
the [ __ ]
news and i show you all the [ __ ] that
you need to know to go out there and arm
yourself to lean into democracy what you
need to know to start talking to folks
around you and show them who these
[ __ ] fascists are they're not
semi-fascist i mean you know joe biden
he had to be nice
he joe biden has to be nice he has to be
diplomatic i guess you could say
semi-fascist is not the [ __ ] word i
would use i would words that use netsy
christian nash white christian
nationalist these america first let's go
brandon nazis yeah we just need to call
them out and we do that here on the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
facebooks
so wherever you are out there this
morning welcome welcome welcome to the
[ __ ] list roundup now someone says um
here on
youtube nazis the national the national
christians nationalist christians the
nazis
they're nazis
i can't even believe that's a brand they
want to have is christian nationalist
holy [ __ ]
you know they're always like oh
then the nazis were national socialist
yeah they weren't socialist
that's not what they were they were
hiding behind that word
is what they were they were hiding
behind that word
just like you're hiding behind the word
christian you dumb [ __ ]
we went over this yesterday with texas
paul the midas mighty favorite
i posted our conversation with paul that
sumbitch was an hour long
we just can't stop talking when we get
talking to texas paul we can't stop so
that's on the youtube channel go
subscribe right now while you're on the
youtube channel if you're on facebook or
twitter
or twitch go over to the youtube page
and subscribe you can watch that entire
conversation we had with texas paul
yesterday on these christian
nationalists
trying to stoke up fear for this
election because they're terrified
they're terrified that we're gonna win
because i really believe that we're
going to so let's get into the tweety
tweets and trendy trends i got a lot of
video to show you here today here is um
here's alex jones holy actual [ __ ] this
guy is losing his
mind
now you know we covered the alex jones
uh
trial
now we covered the part where they were
trying to decide how much money
and i believe the amount of money ended
up being like 4.1 million bucks
is what it was which is not near enough
not near enough
but as alex jones um starts to uh
gear up for his little his next one
because he's got another one another
defamation suit in connecticut
which doesn't have the same type of laws
in texas where they limit the amount
that you have to pay
your victim because of greg abbott by
the way that is a craig abbott thing
greg abbott had to pay victims so when
he became governor he capped the amount
that you have to pay your victims so
that's why alex jones got away and
pretty much scot-free here
i'm paying the amount that he should
have paid in texas and he's only i think
he's on the hook for like
4.1 million or something like that
something like that just over 4 million
which is not near enough
not near enough they need to take
everything from this [ __ ]
but here is alex jones talking to god
knows who here i have no idea who this
is i don't know who this guy is
um
i don't know
but holy [ __ ]
is this guy freaking the [ __ ] out listen
alex jones here do you feel responsible
for what happened to the sandy hook
families yes i killed the children
what
look at this guy's face
so i don't know who this guy is at
channel 5 or world news 5. he forgot to
iron his shirt
whoever this guy is here
he didn't he didn't do his hair he
forgot to iron his shirt he just took
this shirt out of the package
you can still see the uh
the packaging folds guy couldn't even
put the [ __ ] shirt in the dryer
i mean he literally just took this out
of the package
gabe you know what i'm talking about
this look at this guy with the with the
creases on the shirt gotta iron it gotta
steam it yeah well either that or at
least get it put it in the dryer with a
wet towel for a little bit mm-hmm
something yeah something there's all
kinds of drinks yeah put some water use
the body heat you know kind of iron it
out what is this channel 5 thing i don't
even know what this is do you know what
this is i have no idea what this is i've
seen them before oh really yeah yeah
i've seen them like in the alex jones
universe or just no right no no just on
youtube oh okay i've seen them promoted
uh i've seen some people on youtube
yeah yeah huh well i i mean i don't know
i don't know i could be it could be more
than that but i but i've seen their
stuff on youtube like if i were to go to
youtube and i searched the channel right
very strange anyway i haven't seen this
clip so i don't know we haven't seen
this oh let me back it up then because
we just started
you know alex jones is gearing up for
his defamation trial in connecticut
and and the problem with connecticut
that he's going to have is that they
don't have the laws to protect him like
texas did because what was the amount
that he was he was going to have to pay
like 4.1 million or something like total
with the fines and everything yeah and
the actual restitution it was like 4.1
or something like that yeah
it wasn't near enough well with fines it
was 5.6 i think that that that's right
that's right because uh i'm i'm
discounting that he had fines for not
actually cooperating and and the judge
and the court had fined him um for being
alex jones basically
i mean
but isn't it isn't this guy andrew he's
a comedian right i i don't know i don't
know who this is oh yeah i think he's
well i think he's trolling honestly if
if alex jones is willing to do
interviews with youtubers i would go to
austin
i would go to austin to talk to alex
jones oh [ __ ] i would love i would love
to get a chance to stand within spinning
distance of alex jones i'm just saying
what's up
because you know i i'd wanna i'd wanna
give him his due um but but here this
interview this is just a couple minutes
long but alex jones is freaking the [ __ ]
out and i think he's freaking out
because
he paid a bunch of money in texas not
near enough but a bunch of money but he
knows connecticut is not going to be a
good situation because there's not the
laws that greg abbott passed to protect
people from paying victims
um like greg abbott did in texas yeah so
alex jones knows he's in big trouble in
connecticut because there's another i
think there's another case in texas even
yeah yeah he's likely to pay several oh
yeah he's got yeah he's got one more in
connecticut and one more in texas yeah
okay i'm pretty sure if i remember
correctly andrew is well he's a comedian
and i think he's just a satirist so he's
if i if i have to predict this is all
he's all just trolling alex jones but
alex jones i don't think he's gonna tell
for it or just alex jones no one else
will interview him
uh no i don't think that he knows who he
is i don't think he would well who knows
i mean alex jones might be willing to
let anyone ask him questions can you see
if you can message this guy then and see
if we can answer because i want to yeah
i want to ask him about this because
this tape is
watch his watch his face he's actually
scared here at some points he i mean
he's trying his best here but watch this
yeah do you feel responsible for what
happened to the sandy hook families yes
i killed the children
look at his face look at his face yes i
killed the children this guy's like what
what what the [ __ ] did you just say now
i think i think if this guy is a
satirist then in this clip alex jones
realizes this because as we go on you'll
realize why but look at his first
reaction he's like what the [ __ ] did he
just say
this is this is weird let's get keep
going
but beyond that no i mean i went in that
school i pulled a gun out i shot every
one of them myself i mean i'm i'm i'm
guilty it's true no but i don't know
let's just do i feel responsible that
someone
on on play shoot him up video games on a
bunch of drugs went and killed a bunch
of kids and then the internet questioned
it and i covered that no i don't feel
responsible and i don't apologize
anymore i'm done
i don't apologize i killed the kids
it really feels like to me that alex
jones caught on quickly this person was
because if it's true this guy is a
satirist
and he's there to kind of you know one
up on alex jones this guy's like whoa
[ __ ] you're really performing here alex
you're giving me a piece of content
that's gonna make me famous yeah there
are certainly you know
you know you could
i don't know who i mean
we've seen we've seen the
uh
the um
the daily show and the player show and
they do they do these bits where they
ask questions and they re they cut
things around you know enough right
right to get to shine them in a sec
whatever right it's a satirical light
but this doesn't seem like
i don't know if there's too much editing
happening here
i don't know he's just freaking out
let's yeah let's keep watching the the
full-on freak out here of alex i think
it's delicious really i mean i think
it's no no yeah i'm just saying like uh
yeah the reaction by alex jones like i
don't i don't know if he if andrew had
to
edit much of it you know right he just
went with it
was there a definition no i killed him
i killed him you didn't kill him no i
did they didn't no everybody said no no
i killed him
i killed him i already did it i did it i
killed him
i'm the bad guy i'm the devil get rid of
the first amendment
topics i don't think i killed him first
amendment killed him sec get rid of the
second amendment get rid of the first
amendment they're bad they killed the
kids too george washington killed him
jesus killed him
oh my god jesus killed him gave jesus
this guy
this guy do you think this will be do
you think this will be used as evidence
in the next trial oh absolutely why
wouldn't it i mean especially if the
judge in connecticut is anything like
the last judge in austin yeah the last
judge in austin was having none
none of alex jones antics like none of
them like no you were a dumb
[ __ ] we are going to play this
game the way the courts play this game
not the way you play the game right and
and here alex jones is just in full
freakout mode and i really think it's
because
number one he did he did lose and not
only did he lose
but those [ __ ] cell phone records man
he is [ __ ] because connecticut's the
case in connecticut's gonna get those
yeah the new case in texas and it's not
gonna be like they had these records
last minute like they did in the last
case in austin these [ __ ] the
entire discovery is gonna be about those
[ __ ] cell phone records not only them
but the january 6 committee well you
know that those are subpoenaed by them
so he's sweating bullets here and and i
would imagine that the people that he
was in in in threads with on his cell
phone are freaking the [ __ ] out too on
him and there's a lot of pressure being
put on him yeah um and and and it's
obvious that dodgers run over you know
yeah who stager rhone
that name sounds familiar it sounds like
oath keepers oath keepers news today by
the way we're going to talk about that
but let's finish here um
with this dumb [ __ ] first whoo baby he's
boiling over oh we should rename the
whole planet sandy hook everything it
should be holidays
we should bow five times a day to new
haven connecticut for the kids that died
every american's to blame every gun
owners are blamed i'm to blame we are
all guilty to bloomberg and soros turn
our guns in turn our guns in i know i
did it i killed them i killed them i
killed them i i know i killed them
so i'm done talking about it
i killed them okay
can we talk about the trial at all
[Laughter]
okay i get i get you don't want to talk
about sandy hook yeah yeah but uh can we
go ahead and move on to the trial is
that a thing that you're willing to
freak out about so so is that still on
the table yeah is that is that something
we can talk about oh man let's let's
let's i haven't i haven't watched the
end of this i just watched the first of
the free cap let's let's listen
there's nothing to talk about let me
tell you i don't know if i can do this
interview right now
you liking it
so this is the hot mic doing that what
dude i murdered those children
i didn't i killed myself still not a
funny thing to say yeah i get the point
but it's just
like [ __ ] it i don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah this is definitely going to be
used this is 100
going to be entered into evidence and
played during the next trial i didn't
watch the whole thing i only watched
like the first 30 seconds because here's
the thing i i wouldn't be surprised if
they went to andrew and they're like hey
can we get the full like unedited audio
or like like stuff and then they'd be
like yeah sure you can have it i don't
care man this guy's [ __ ] crazy like
take it
and do with it what you want
oh my god it is
whoosh
that is something else crazy some
[ __ ]
and then the the the best part is uh the
after when he's got the hot mic on
oh yeah you think alex jones would know
that he's got a
that is also one of those things where
it's like oh you know
whether you try to play the
the defense of
i you know i'm crazy i'm insane it's
like no you know what you're saying
and
you're saying it in a malicious way
and
it is not going to help your defense
you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ]
because also the other thing too is like
now
in texas we know exactly what the
limitation or the cap max
on the damages are
so it could possibly you know like what
happens
in the next round could be awarded more
maybe i don't know
i have no idea i think um
trying to see if there's another clip it
doesn't appear to be i i i actually
uh tweeted this thing on and said uh
alex jones should open up a true social
account because this is the kind of [ __ ]
we've seen from
from the cheeto dust mobster to be
honest with you this kind of stuff he
doesn't he doesn't have it on his
youtube channel so it's it's not up yet
you mean you mean the whole interview
yeah well anything of the interview the
last thing it has is from four days ago
of something else one account put this
up here
um i don't know where they pulled this
from
it says andrew callahan from channel 5
news on youtube
this is his account's called channel 5
news
yeah yeah that's okay
let's see let's see if we can let's see
if we can reach out to andrew and
callahan and see if we can get it and
talk to him about what the hell happened
um on this interview i just found out he
was also on he was just on hot ones what
is that i don't know what that is hot
ones is i'm a boomer man it's it's like
a talk show kind of it's an interview
talk show where they eat the hot wings
you know they go through you ever seen
those things
they go through they go through like
seven or so wings and they you know at
the end they put the dab on but they're
asking questions along the way to learn
more oh my god tony after the show after
the show
he's going to be all up in he's going to
be all about my [ __ ] dms go to
youtube and just super with the
you
goddamn
me on the show today that's what he's
going to say you embarrassed i'm going
to say you embarrassed me you
embarrassed me look at this i look like
an idiot now speaking of embarrassing
idiots
holy [ __ ] the guy is up this morning
gabe dude is up posting about his weight
i'm not [ __ ] you
i'm not the guy says not only did the
fbi steal my passports they didn't steal
your passwords they were in the [ __ ]
boxes they were in the boxes
everyone is supposed to believe this
this guy's not a slob but he didn't
unpack his [ __ ] from a year and a half
ago come on give me a [ __ ] break yeah
and and again the fact that he knew the
passports were missing
means that he knew where they were in
the boxes with the documents that he
should not have had would she know what
documents were in which box he was put
in the certain boxes certain pots places
so he could show like kyle rittenhouse
marjorie taylor green you know top
secret nuclear foreign secrets um but he
goes on to say here and i think the best
part of this [ __ ] post is when he
says
um and they also improperly took my
complete and highly confidential medical
file in history
wait a second so oh my god so the most
classified thing that he's mad and he's
like the doj and the fbi have
confidential records like that's what
he's saying here yeah he's saying
he's saying what they're they're saying
they're not confidential well i mean to
an extent sure but i mean like we
already know he's a fat ass right and
he's very unhealthy we know those things
i mean maybe he had these things stuffed
in that box these are government records
because this is a government medical
exam
yeah well i wouldn't be surprised if the
reason that he is very upset about his
confidential medical file being taken
is because remember well one he got
coveted but two do you remember when he
had that late night trip nobody knew
about until after the fact he went to
read medical oh yeah and they said it
was some sort of they're like oh it's
routine it's a routine checkup but
you'll be like nobody does a routine
checkup in the middle of the night and a
lot of people were beginning to theorize
that maybe
uh donald trump had some mini strokes
right and then he went online or they or
they were like or they were
that that that that he had to get the
symptoms of ministry right right right
and he went online he's like you don't
know many strokes and then he had a
stroke uh but
i wouldn't be surprised if he's also
worried because there are things in that
physical like you have a weird small
dick and you had many strokes
looks like a cheeto right or the fact
that those the mocha test which is the
cognitive
uh testing can't stop talking about that
right still i wouldn't be surprised if
in that medical file which again it
doesn't test aptitude or your iq it's to
make sure like where you are in the
range of like are you developing science
of dementia are you like can you
remember [ __ ] yeah yeah remember it
doesn't you know just because you ace it
great but it doesn't take a genius
to do it oh but it does gabe oh but it
does because these files are highly
classified highly top secret
confidential information and they stole
it and they're the criminals i'm just
saying there's only there's only you
know i'm just trying to think of the
things that he would find to be
embarrassing or he would worry about and
those are things in my mind
that come out because i see also he's
talking about his personal tax records
well okay so let me get to that he says
with all the bells and whistles in the
medical file what the [ __ ] is that i
have no idea his weight that's what he's
worried about because in parentheses he
says at least they'll see that i'm very
healthy an absolute perfect physical
specimen i'm like what the [ __ ] he
actually no for anyone out there
listening that can't see the screen here
i'm telling you this [ __ ] typed
this out he said he said about himself
at least they'll see
that i'm a very healthy and absolutely
perfect
physical
specimen
[Music]
oh my god if you're still following this
fool and you read that
get the [ __ ] out of here and then he
goes on to say like you putting it out
plus my personal tax returns and he in
parentheses again he likes that all of a
sudden he doesn't like quotes in this
one yeah he likes the parentheses he
says illegal to take which
they're not illegal to take what is he
talking about
well the other thing here is that he
says my personal tax records right so
we only know
about a few years right which is when he
applied for the casino he had to sew
those but everything else has been i've
been in audit this has been an audit uh
the irs is auditing me and i can't i
can't release someone right now probably
why you know even if they are really in
audit which i doubt or they're just back
and forth on like what information
they're sharing
you know again probably another reason
why he's afraid of the 47 000 irs agents
that are coming for him over 10 years if
he'll make it that long oh they're
coming for him but
his personal tax records he's like oh
this is [ __ ] you know uh it's
because it's gonna show that he
he makes no money or he made no money or
he you know was entering certain things
in for loopholes and trying to take
advantage of the tax code right which he
said in the speech goes that makes me
smart it doesn't make you smart it makes
you a [ __ ] scumbag is what it makes
you right you the the president or at
that point was the uh running to be
president of the united states are out
there bragging about how you took all
these tax loopholes and saved so much
money and that makes you special it's
like you're a [ __ ] criminal right it
sounds like you not paying taxes is not
paying your fair share which means
everyone else has to cover for your fat
ass and now they are the ones hey hey
he's a perfect physical specimen god
damn it
sorry his perfectly specimen ass and
what in what world in what world is that
guy if you've seen a picture of him here
lately it would you define it as perfect
physical special i mean really honestly
well he said doctor he said he said in a
recent speech i think he was at the
rally in in pennsylvania he said that
uh dr oz oh said he was in
in good health oh
you can lose 20 to 30 pounds but i'm
okay 20 30 pounds that's a lot of weight
that's a lot of weight that's why i
don't need to lose 20 or 30 pounds
that's not easy man that [ __ ] 23 pounds
is is a lot to lose but
especially especially when mcdonald's
and donuts are sitting around yeah
you're not gonna it's gonna be difficult
to lose 20 30 pounds i mean when you're
the president you know a perfectly
specimen president
and you have at your disposal
a goddamn uh red heating lamp for your
french fries and your burgers at
whatever hour you want made out of the
kitchen you know to wrap them up and
[ __ ]
it's gonna add some weight all right we
know we also know that this guy that
trusts me mcdonald's adds the weight it
does fast food packs it on the other
thing too is like this guy is not we
know obviously he's not a perfect
perfect
physical specimen
you know
because even after the uh 2020 election
after he lost
again trump lost the election
so everyone else can stop crying about
this [ __ ]
he lost the election and afterward the
oval office smelled like flatulence aka
it smelled like farts fast food farts
and people going in they were [ __ ]
like candles i'm not joking
anyone farts anyone can look this up
right now
trump
flatulence oval office 2020 you'll find
the articles so let's go back to the the
physical specimen thing yeah because i
think we haven't beat this dead horse
enough
so if you go back and you look at uh
former presidents like i don't know
jimmy carter's like in his 90s and he's
still building houses
yeah you got you got
george w bush and bill clinton they like
to ride bikes
joe biden can ride bikes he likes to
bike he likes to cycle as the
professionals say
and then you have you have barack obama
surfing can you imagine can you imagine
this perfect perfect physical specimen
on a surfboard or a bicycle get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] no way the
[ __ ] way so presidents are known as
super agers right so presidents have
become super agers because they've act
one right they have security what do you
mean by super agents you like they live
a long time yeah so super agers are are
classified as people who live well
beyond the the range of a normal human
right they're into their 90s and beyond
but it's not they live that long it's
also to live that long and they're you
know in pretty good health and condition
they're able to go about and walk but
the reason
that these presidents have become super
agents is because they have the
top-notch health care right right you
got someone right there like like if
everyone in america had this we would be
in much better shape right but you know
you would just be amazing costs would be
lower it would be great oh yeah but yeah
he's got a doctor he's got a medical
staff on the [ __ ] go wherever he is
he's also transported
by security so there are certain things
he doesn't have to do there are certain
things he's not exposed to which
obviously adds to the longevity of your
life but these other presidents right
bush i mean clinton had to get uh uh
he was he was a big mcdonald's fast food
guy and then he had to change his diet
he had surgery right now he lives a more
healthy life i think he's vegan now if i
remember correctly so like he's made
changes to his own diet i don't know if
he's vegan or he's vegetarian yeah one
of the one of the two i mean i know he
made a change but like if you look at
those people
they're yeah they're living their most
healthy life
because of the things they have access
to trump is like i have access to those
things for the time being let's say
and i'm eating my
myself
into
my grave i
actually i'm i'm i'm encouraging this i
hope the guy eats four buckets of
chicken a day to be honest with you i
mean i
have had it have had it son
go go for it go for it because this
guy's lost his mind look at this [ __ ]
last night this is a post from last
night so i said dude turned on the true
social treason ai feature this is
[ __ ] bonkers man it took me it took
me like five or six times to even get
through this to figure out what the [ __ ]
he was saying here's the thing i did a
dramatic reading and i'll probably
finish it up in the in a moment here and
we can play it on the show this took me
so long to read just want to point this
out the way in which he because this is
what uh
one sentence two sentences wow sort of
well i guess three senses but the
fbi
is there three people oh yeah there is
okay i see the mules okay i see it and
it's in the wrong spot it's in the wrong
spot well no i mean technically that's
the way that everybody is
because i think it looks too weird
especially if i'm quoting something but
if it's a longer statement like there's
a comma then i might throw it in between
but that's the way you're actually
supposed to
based on different uh you know but
that's it
does it feel like with this statement he
had a whole list of [ __ ] he wanted to
say in it and then he just oh yeah
i don't know i don't know how he i don't
know how he put this together because he
may have been having many strokes when
he did this because this is [ __ ] just
absolute garbage word salad i don't i
can't even understand something i don't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about in
some
the problem here is that like again when
i was reading this last night i was
filming the dramatic reading for this i
read through it and
typically i can get through like i can
read it a couple times in my head and be
like all right great this is where i
want the blocks or the breaks to be or
pauses but in this one i was like
okay so the fired fbi agent who was
walked out of the fbi headquarters
building two weeks ago and who said
falsely to facebook and the media you
know it's in this disinformation
like that that whole thought right there
you're like this this guy
this guy who was fired this fbi agent
boom has been a greater resource
right
uh to convince people that the 2020
presidential election was rigged then
like so he's doing has been and then
he's doing a comparison with the tapes
by saying then even it takes you are
thinking way too hard about this this
guy is out of his mind here's the yeah
and i could say
it was difficult to read when i when i
was when i was looking at this
it reminds me of like an seo generator
right like you type in keywords so if
for folks who don't know seo is like
what drives like google and youtube
they're looking for their version
optimization right they're looking well
right but they're looking for these
words inside content
to determine if they should deliver it
to you in their search results right and
if and and there's keyword generators
there's like seo generators out there
that you just you just slam in a a list
of keywords like fbi fbi headquarters
facebook the media
laptop from hell russian disinformation
and he just like slammed it in and then
it spit this out that's what it felt
like to me that's why i was like this
has got to be an a generator it does it
does feel like when you go online and
someone's like i taught you're like you
know because typically how an you know
an ai bot works you have a neural net
and you teach it right uh certain things
right like this is a photo this is a dog
is a tree right but other people have
taught things like hey i'm gonna feed
you ten seasons or nine seasons of
seinfeld right run through and learn
these characters and how they talk
then i want this ai bot to generate a
new episode about
whatever topic
and it's always fun you know when you
rewrite the episode
it'll write a new episode so people will
be like hey check out this one-page
scene that i had an ai bot right for a
seinfeld episode
some lines are funny because they're
like oh yeah that person would say that
and other ones are [ __ ] batshit like
what the hell like it's throwing [ __ ] at
the wall and seeing what sticks but it
really does get confused and this is one
of those things where it's like oh yeah
well it probably threw in random words
or random key phrases and this like you
said a.i feature really does remind me
of that where it's he is it doesn't make
any sense but now he throws it laptop
from hell russian disinformation
thousand mules big election right you
know just all the words that he wants
they got the
capital letters coming in you know
you know
i think i think here's the thing here
though with this with this that it shows
because this was posted last night
so
um he had he had um not had his adderall
in a while um now now it could be
indication that maybe you know because
they say joe biden is a robot or some
[ __ ] maybe donald trump is a robot in a
fat skin suit and this ai is writing
these these uh fraud social posts over
there but i actually believe that
he's very scared he's very terrified
he's like a caged animal here um last
night he couldn't think about anything
anything but these keywords that he's
stewing on and he just absolutely had to
[ __ ] them into this machine
and and post it to the for the public to
see this is this is scary [ __ ] that
these people think that it's a good idea
to hand the country back to this fool
like not only not only are you ignoring
that he's a treasonous piece of [ __ ] but
you're ignoring that this guy is a
[ __ ] lunatic right i mean and that
and that's especially true when you've
got people like marco rubio doubling i
was just gonna pull that clip up
and saying oh guys the thing we should
really be focused about right now
are the leaks the leaks the
yeah i know but it it's one of those
things where you know he goes on i mean
here's the thing and i tweeted it this
morning there are things that the the
republicans have shown us they they they
care more or they think it's a bigger
deal that
uh mar-a-lago was legally searched by
the fbi
they say uh the fbi or they're like oh
we you know they complained about how
the fbi legally searched mar-a-lago how
the fbi photographed these stolen
classified documents those that actually
remained not those that were missing
from the classified folders and then
you've got this third part which is
saying we are more worried about the
fact that the media has been leaked how
serious they haven't been given details
they've just been given info to the
extent of he had these foreign uh this
foreign info of nuclear secrets
in the mix of documents
they never you know they never released
the document they never gave them a
photo but they're giving the public
context to really show like
this uh this opinion that judge or
decision that judge cannon gave on the
special master is [ __ ] ridiculous and
this is the type of stuff that is at
risk because
you as the american people should know
to an extent and have transparency with
what threat we are facing right now with
the former president who has violated
the espionage act and they don't care
about that [ __ ] republicans do not care
that trump is potentially or has sold
our government secrets to a foreign
entity all they care about is whoa whoa
whoa why did you guys take a messy photo
of of those documents or why did you
guys search his home or why is the media
getting leaks about what the documents
contained
it's [ __ ] it's crazy ass [ __ ] man
and i can't believe that marco rubio
is saying what he's saying here but it's
not surprising and the real surprising
thing about this clip is ducey has not
let up on this he's like this guy's a
[ __ ] criminal and because they've
even let bill barr on fox news to be
like yeah dude's going to jail um i mean
not in so many words but you know i
think they knew when they brought bill
barr on that he was going to the first
time no but there's no way the second
time yeah yeah no no [ __ ] way that
they did not know that he was going to
want him up and dunk him in the trash
but listen to do she try to talk some
sense into little marco here no you can
understand why uh you know
when we first heard about this stuff
when we heard well maybe it's things
like a note from kim jong un to
uh president trump that he wanted to
keep his hands on but then
if true this washington post report
highly classified documents at
mar-a-lago
that only a cabinet level officer or
hire could even look at that doesn't
seem like the kind of thing you should
have
uh in your post-presidential
desk drawer
so doozy delivers this up for marco to
go yeah you're right i mean like tries
to hand him
the [ __ ] truth and say look it's easy
for you to
to to kind of walk this back here the
way that i'm delivering it to you and
i'm actually i'm actually surprised here
that fox news especially on fox and
friends is willing to edge up to
journalism and it really is shouldn't be
surprising because i think fox news is
getting a little nervous now that cnn's
trying to compete for their audience
so i think they're really gonna have to
pull back here from the newsmax oan
you know just the crazy queuing on stuff
they're really gonna have to start
participating and i don't know news they
call themselves that they're gonna have
to start participating in it a bit or at
least appear to
but i want to give i want to give ducey
credit here because he did serve this up
to marco easily
to to really uh say what he's saying but
listen to what of course marco rubio
does he's a treasonous piece of [ __ ] and
why this guy is still on the senate
intelligence committee he's beyond me he
even talks about that in here but he
just totally says no you're wrong the
real crime the real crime is what i say
it is let's listen
well let's break this down first of all
again we really don't know because let's
go back and understand that but we do
know yeah we do there's no but we don't
know
we know that he has these documents we
know that there are documents that are
missing that are classified and that
we're trying to track down we know that
he just openly [ __ ] had these things
in his office you know a few in his desk
he had them in boxes or cartons
elsewhere
it's not no it's not there's an
inventory here's the pictures of it the
more we know
the worse it gets
right well i mean that's that's what
they're running into here and that's
what marco's running into here they keep
they have to find
themselves right they can well cornering
this watch down watch him as he says
that
this is this is a leaking issue this is
a leak it's a leak issue
well you gotta fix that diaper leak all
of this information is coming from one
side and one place
and that is sources with knowledge of
the engine yeah yeah it's called um uh
what's that agency called gabe that does
um justice what is that called again oh
it's a department of oh that's right
that's right yeah do you see that's the
other craziest part about these it's
one-sided
right one yeah
yeah one-sided for justice yeah you are
such a dumbass that this is ridiculous
honestly the department of justice
didn't want to do what it had to do
because donald trump decided to get
judge ken and his is bought and paid for
judge involved but they did and that's
the only reason why we know this [ __ ]
marco it isn't because of the department
of justice they were forced to release
this stuff
we would never we would never know these
things if it were not for trump and
republicans doubling down to say he's
the victim and the department of justice
has no right
i'm going to show you a new clip it's
going to make a beautiful shitty legal
take so i'm going to show you another
after this one
but let's listen a little marco here
give his take his really shitty take on
why it's okay for trump to have top
secret classified nuclear secrets of a
foreign power investigation well who are
the sources of knowledge of the
investigation the fbi and the justice
department and they are leaking to the
media
so generally and when there's an
investigation by the fbi or justice
department they're not even
acknowledging there is an investigation
much less leaking
they weren't until trump did
and it's not a leak it's not a leak when
they're filing a motion
in court you dumb [ __ ] you guys
made the mess you realized that right
that you know what it reminds me of if
anyone out there or you have watched uh
i think you should leave with tim
robinson it's a show he's a former snl
writer but he has a show a couple
seasons on netflix and in the first
season he's got this bit where he's uh
he uh this hot dog
car
drives through a retail store and
everyone's like oh my god what the hell
happened they're going to check it and
all of a sudden tim robinson is in a hot
dog costume he's like guys we should
really figure out who caused this like
who's the one who did this meanwhile
he's a hot dog or he's a hot dog costume
and there's a hot dog car and everyone's
like no we know it was you and he goes
guys i don't think you understand we
need to figure out who did it
so if paul this is that listening maybe
you should put
marco rubio on a hot dog costume here
i'm just saying that might make this
video much better much more watchable if
marco ruby was i mean really marco would
be much more watchable if he was in a
hot dog costume like right but that's
the time that's what it reminds me of is
all the time whenever a politician it's
not just the it's not just the right or
republicans but when people on the left
democrats do but typically it's mainly
republicans and an example like this is
guys we've got this problem it's like
yeah but you you you were the one who
[ __ ] drove it in you drove it the car
into the retail store you're the one
who's complaining about this stuff being
out in the open because you guys keep
challenging and accusing the doj and the
fbi of making this [ __ ] up and they have
to say we're not making this up and to
prove that we're not making it up here's
a photo here's a list here's this here's
that they keep filing motions they keep
filing motions to get the doj to say
this [ __ ] let's listen these people
every single day are strategically
leaking information that can't be
rebutted by the way or in any way
analyzed no because it's true politics
to influence the narrative and so i'm
first of all very skeptical of that i
also the whole thing about only cabinet
officials could know that that's not the
way classification works
classification is based on both the
compartment the way it's classified at
what level and then the need to know
basis the third thing i would say is
that um you know as a member of the gang
of eight which is the eight officials in
congress with which that should stop
today this guy should not be in the gang
of anything yeah not in the gang of
anything
let's listen inside to intelligence
we're read into all kinds of things
all the time never once were we ever
approached and told there is this
massive uh brewing counter intelligence
why would they united states and we want
to make you aware of it and because they
knew you would run down there and tell
him
they would do they would do the exact
same thing that devin nunes whenever
there was some sort of issue definitely
running down oh my god
president trump president trump you
wouldn't you won't believe what they
just said about you and then he runs
back to the [ __ ] capital
oh my god it is that is exactly why it's
like why do you think they don't want
this information leaked why do you think
they don't want to reveal certain people
that are witnesses because you guys will
attack them you guys will will will go
behind and say hey trump look at this is
what we're looking into right now
like when you when you know the guy has
documents if you give them a heads up
that only means that he would get rid of
the documents again or or more or he
would burn them bury them uh tear them
up eat them i don't know
but if if if they were given a heads up
they would 100 go to trump and say hey
look we're looking into you for
supposedly stealing these documents and
you go oh [ __ ] okay
and now here is here is uh here is
uh habba
and she's been the um the star of a tv
show that we've been releasing here
recently the the sitcom called shitty
legal takes because boy does she have
him um you know he um gabe does works
his magic on these clips where he adds a
an intro from it seems like a late 80s
early 90s sitcom
called shitty legal takes and then he
puts all you do is just put laugh tracks
was this
was this my idea of course it's your
magic that you work here but yeah you
texted me one night and you said that's
right what if we
uh well because i was trying to figure
out what we could do with it yeah you
were like can you
you're like can we put a laugh track and
i was like yeah and i'll do you one
better
yeah
yeah because because i was trying to
figure out how to make because i was
like this is hilarious the stuff that
they're saying like i was laughing as
they were saying i'm like there needs to
be a laugh track of this now i remember
and then you came up with the the shitty
the [ __ ] yeah and i was like i've got an
idea and then you're like okay i don't
know what it is but what show what show
does it feel like what show does it's um
i i took uh
the music is from i don't know like
family matters oh okay
it's like it's like a
a moment it's a transition like right
music it's just their bumper into the
show yeah yeah or i think it actually
might be pulled between a scene oh okay
okay yeah just just a bumper in between
the scene but here is we haven't done
this to this clip here but i'm sure oh
i'm sure
i'm sure the video department will work
their magic today because these are easy
to make you know what you just throw on
the thing you behind the laptops throw
them on there boom you got it you got a
sitcom of shitty legal takes here's
habba let's listen incredibly disturbing
to me um in terms of leaks coming from
the justice department see more about
the leaks they're more disturbed yeah
they're more disturbed about the leaks
they don't care republican parties
secret documents being leaked out of his
office the republican party is the
anti-american party they don't give a
[ __ ] that trump had these documents or
the fact that trump was potentially
selling or or or sold or show had
shown these documents in the past they
don't care about that
they care about making this about the
leaks about how they photograph the
messy pile of documents about uh how
they search the the the property of
mar-a-lago they want to make it seem
like he's the victim which is their
[ __ ] 101 he is the victim of being a
perfect physical specimen here that is
why they're after him okay
okay perfect human specimen you know
what you know what it that you know what
that reminds me of who what uh white
supremacists oh you say oh we're the
perfect uh
where the supreme race right that type
of perfect
perfect healthy specimen gives me the
same vibes right you're getting that
you're getting that little dick energy
i'm getting that you're claiming you're
better than people but you're actually
way below oh my god well you know what's
funny is yesterday habbo was saying
something totally different she wasn't
saying about the leaks yeah she's
talking invisible documents right she
was talking about invisible documents
and how ridiculous it is that the media
is focused on the the folders that he
stole documents out of like and then
instagram meme yeah she was used that
was her legal take was she's on as his
attorney this isn't like
this is not as if she is
shut you know i said this before i was
like dude if i were them i would shut
the [ __ ] up but for me my personal
advice is don't stop right i mean i love
the shitty legal takes now i really want
them to continue so and i love the case
they're making right against themselves
okay let's let's listen to more in this
case because it's horrible
the fact that
you know we had originally and let's
remember the timeline here originally
there were nuclear codes
and the latest and greatest is
that's not what was said by them no they
said
right they never said
people online like us [ __ ] posters
online were saying nuclear codes they
did say there were nuclear documents
right which now we know they're there
possibly are from
uh
no one said nuclear codes i mean we
don't know who knows maybe maybe there
is right but but the reason why there
wouldn't be nuclear codes is because
those codes wouldn't work anymore
exactly
i mean maybe he took them as a as you
know i don't know i mean like if they're
if they're still going with the excuse
that laura trump said which was oh he
likes to collect these things and no
rubble like she's she's making the
argument put him on his mantle yeah he
likes to scrapbook yeah and at his old
and on the wall you know he really got
into knitting and scrapbooking
and that's what he needs those kids for
that's a great legal take by the way
let's listen you know there's empty
folders and now they're saying there's
they're not saying right they're not
saying information about another country
this is people are people are not saying
they gave a list yeah gave a list of
this [ __ ] and really honestly i'm sure
someone who knows a damn
good amount of [ __ ] about classified
information could look through that list
and go yep that's probably the nuclear
secrets that's probably the nuclear
secrets the way they're marking [ __ ]
great
you know when you have to defend
yourself stories come out
when
and that's exactly what i believe they
are just stories right ah here we go
with the story singing and this is what
i tweeted about it that that it's not
stories it's motions filed
in federal court like i get that the
washington post thing with the nuclear
thing is a story
but not the list of documents not that
he had empty folders that is not a story
that's not a cute little [ __ ]
children's book that's not
that is a real [ __ ] thing that ended
up on an inventory sheet when the fbi
went and searched his [ __ ] is his
scuzzy ass scummy home down at
mar-a-lago and look through these boxes
and inventory this [ __ ] that is an
inventory that is not a story that is a
real [ __ ] document that is filed in
federal court and that is where they're
gonna lose on this every [ __ ] day of
the week that they think they can just
sell this as a story it's not a story
[ __ ] this is this is evident
like evidence this is not like giuliani
and jenna ellis thinking that oh we've
got legal theories we got a bunch of
theories guys we don't have evidence but
we got theories this isn't the same
thing the doj and the fbi aren't going
to open up an investigation show a judge
hey here's the affidavit here's the
evidence we need to sign off on the
search warrant so we can execute it
they're not going to make that [ __ ] up
right they're not gonna go about and say
hey we have these documents and then
show up be like yeah we found these
documents or at least we found some of
them because the other ones are missing
and we still don't know where they are
and and we've we've got a documented
account of communication between nara
and trump and his lawyers going back and
forth saying they have the documents
they don't have the documents we've got
the documents here are some of the
documents we need more documents i'm
saying okay we give you more documents
hiding the documents and causing the fbi
to come get the documents that are that
are very sensitive to anyone who is not
cabinet level or has been granted access
like we discovered yesterday right this
is something that you could just kind of
wash away and be like ah he just had
this document it's a storage story it's
a great it's a great children's story
well here's the other thing too here's
the other thing dude is that they can
keep doing this but it is going to make
it worse and worse and also
for sure i mean
they keep backing themselves like you
said let's encourage them to do yeah for
by all means please keep talking keep
embarrassing yourself keep making these
terrible legal takes because i guarantee
that things you say on these tv shows
will be used against you when you say
well what did you mean when you said
this right and then we'll obviously have
the court record of the person saying
well we don't actually have evidence to
prove that you planted it
we don't have evidence to prove this
claim or this claim it's it's going to
be the same thing rudy giuliani went
through with the 2020 election stuff he
makes a claim on tv they ask him about
the claim in court and he says we don't
actually have that we don't actually
have real affidavits we don't actually
have evidence to back up our claim that
we made about this government but the
doj does here and the other thing if you
notice and and i'm gonna finish this up
here because i want to move on to the
steve bannon story um but
the other thing that you noticed here is
that they're not talking about uh the
the fact
that that he declassified them anymore
right there that
bill barr threw cold water all over that
like that's even worse if you
declassified nuclear secrets of a
foreign power like they can't now say
well these are declassified secrets from
a foreign power that has to do with
their nuclear capability it's probably
one of our allies by the way yeah it's
probably what it is if you really think
about trump and how he would use it but
let's listen so at this point if you
look at the left-wing media storytelling
it's inconsistent it's outrageous
and it's
and it's been all over the map
all over the map gabe are all over the
map with this story we have changed our
story a hundred times gabe we are are
not
in living ah you gotta love that
projection tony you gotta love the
projection well speaking of um
of not living in reality let's go to
this one real quick before we get to the
steve bannon i want to show you this
who is still watching this guy and not
making fun of him like literally who
this is on i think
i want to imagine the people watching
steve bannon now i mean outside of
marjorie taylor green and her car oh i'm
talking about mike glendale oh mike
lindell i'm talking about michael if
you're watching the mypelo nazi and not
making fun of him oh yeah doing you're
doing the content i just want to know i
want to know how and how much money mike
lindell still has and where he's funny
because he certainly doesn't have the
outlets he used to uh like you said that
the odds they killed the product being
sold there i don't know how many other
places i also not only do i get text
messages on my burner phone from donald
trump i also get text messages from mike
lindell which was everything yeah from
where from what what entity you uh from
frank social
are you serious did you sign up over
there i signed up oh okay and so every
day i get paid how is sprint social
these days it's a piece of [ __ ]
every day better or worse than true
social which is it's worse it looks whoa
like like you mean like because you're
you're talking about the design yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna design
yourself aesthetically it looks worse
the navigation isn't much better i mean
they're both shitty websites let's be
honest they're bullshitting look at this
crackhead do you think he can develop a
decent website no not at all i mean when
he announced it he was like we're gonna
have frankspeach.com it's gonna be the
number one social network it's gonna be
if youtube and twitter had a baby like
that's the one that described it's gonna
be like it's gonna be like if all the
people on there are perfect human
specimens right wink wink well you know
just look at the background here with
the folded flag this has this has this
has really high bone spur donald trump
jr energy that was purchased on amazon i
can guarantee it what's the [ __ ]
certificate thing there what does that
what is that i can't tell you different
kid of
craziness i don't know does this mean
he's certifiably crazy and then i love
the jesus lion picture on the other side
oh that's [ __ ] sweet oh that is
[ __ ] sweet i actually want to get one
of those and hang out hang that [ __ ] up
behind me um but no this is a
certificate of something but he's got
the pin here he's always got the pin
because he's got to be taking notes
um you know of how many machines there
are and how many
percentages
i don't know what he's talking about
let's listen i have really great news um
well call great news um it's four
percent there's only four percent of
those counties so far that cyber guys
have looked at the cyber guys he's got
got gabe he's got cyber guys do you
think they have that printed on their
business card yeah like i know what the
dell's cyber gay
i know what that sign that certificate
says now what is it because once you
start playing its certificate of
excellence which i think is ironic crazy
it is it is beautiful certificate of
certificate of excellence i don't know
him
uh
michael give it michael isn't his middle
name jay isn't it michael j lindell i
guess you know i'm i'm going to print a
certificate of excellence too
it's his it says it's michael j lindell
i don't know who it's from but it's a
certificate of excellence
someone someone somewhere is going to
find us a picture of this thing a decent
resolution so we can zoom in and
recreate this [ __ ] thing
i'm i want one with my name on it um
let's listen so here's what he's saying
he's saying that all the all the
counties that his cyber guys you know
the crackheads that he's got working for
him these cyber guys only four percent
of them the machines weren't tampered
with that's what he's saying but let's
let's continue the nonsense
that are not compromised in other words
96
of all the counties we've went through
already which is hundreds of them have
all been machine manipulated and they
and this is a hundred percent evidence
so and okay so
here's the thing we know now from a
story about sydney powell
and and a county in georgia that these
[ __ ] were going into these
counties and tampering with these
machines the i.t guys so i don't know if
sydney powell's it guy is the same mike
glendale cyber guy that's going in and
tampering with machines it really feels
like to me that they actually went and
tampered with machines so they could
point at it and go look it was tampered
with right literally it feels like
that's what they're going to start to do
here i mean i think that's
that is a good point is when they get in
trouble right they want to claim oh look
you know the the fbi is is attacking me
that proves that this or whatever right
and i think in this same scenario
they use their own guilt
as an admission or proof
that it is flawed right the accusation
they made about this thing saying like
oh
these machines can be easily manipulated
by people if they want to hack into them
let's say
and they get busted for that very thing
and they're like see i told you i told
you people were hacking into them people
were taking over the machines and
manipulating the votes i told you guys i
was right i'm not [ __ ] crazy and
you're like no you're not you're out of
your mind and you're a criminal is what
you are
but
it is the exact same thing when they get
busted they turn around and go whoa whoa
whoa guys we this is the exact thing
that we warned you about right you know
it's like look someone's gonna rob this
bank and then you rob the bank like see
i told you i told you they were gonna
run back you [ __ ]
speaking of speaking to dumb [ __ ] that
do this kind of [ __ ] where they they
they break things and then claim that
they're broken and then they're like
look we'll fix it uh the build the wall
guy um steve bannon was pardoned for
federal charges on the we build it
called we build a wall is that what it's
called the fun that he actually uh deep
brought it from the gofundme was it the
go fund me like
yeah i i don't know but i think it's
called we we will build the wall or
something yeah
i don't know what the official name was
but it was the wall building yeah we we
built the wall charity it was a charity
right so as a 501c3 and they actually
didn't do any charity they stole the
money which is a felony several of them
right classic right who would have
thought right who would have thought
that the people that were associated
with trump would be [ __ ]
uh you know right frauds when you open a
charity for when you when you you
yourself opens a 501c3
and you get a
certain tax exemption from the federal
government they're like yeah you have to
use this money in a certain way to
remain a 501c3 and you have to make sure
of it and steve bannon's like yeah i'm
just going to put in my [ __ ] pocket
now what's funny about this is trump
only only pardoned him from these yeah
well remember he also i don't know if
people know this but trump did give
and and i believe the phrase was his
blessing
because he said
you know this is trump's baby in the
sense of trump was like we're going to
build a wall it's going to be so amazing
that piece of shit's falling apart i can
tell you right now well but this wasn't
a time when democrats were pushing back
and he wasn't getting getting the
funding that he wanted so they they used
it to politicize it and create this
circus and to give them and and what
they always do
is to politicize it so that their
followers will give them money yep and
they took the money and trump gave it
his blessing he said yeah yeah that's
good you do that is it the same thing
that he does with classified documents
when he waves his big mac stained hands
and says no i think this is one blessing
i bless this i trump bless this moment i
think you know you know that scene in
lion king where they're like simba you
know oh yeah i think what trump wants is
he like takes a little bit of his orange
ketchup maybe it's
ketchup right and then he just goes
simba
or he goes
and he goes
blessing and he just blessed it and
that's what he did yeah
so he's expect but here's the breaking
news came last night as steve bannon and
i think steve bannon is the one who
released this statement um uh and we'll
look at that here in a second steve
bannon um said that he was expect he was
going to be indicted today and tomorrow
is going to be in um
to go for arraignment
so the the news was is that he'll
surrender to state prosecutors on
thursday to face a criminal indictment
in the state of new york this is a state
indictment that his pardon does not
cover because
in the grand scheme of things and this
one mueller she wrote has from
washington post and i think that was the
um the original
uh
people who broke this story from steve
bannon's
statement his public statement
but that's the one thing that they
really didn't count on was being
pardoned federally they can't trump is
not the governor of new york so he can't
pardon him in the state of new york
which is a problem
and i'm sure he'll claim executive
privilege or some stupid [ __ ] here that
is i have executive privilege over every
statement right i'm the president and
it's like former and we'll see if you
still have that title right right right
right soon soon soon you'll be in charge
of nothing uh christopher here has the
uh statement now he says i wonder if
steve bannon realized the last part of
his statement reads more like the beacon
of hope than a threat um and if you look
at his statement here here's what he's
talking about this is the end of steve
bannon's statement here where he he of
course it's probably this is this like
an iphone note
i don't know like i don't know i
honestly don't know where he posted this
i don't know if he posted on some sort
yeah like i don't i don't know if this
is a quote of him and then it's a
summation of something but this looks
like
when somebody makes an apology and
they're like i don't have enough
characters or i can't do it or you're
doing a draft right you're right right
and they yeah and they post a note on it
on instagram or something like here are
my thoughts and that way you can do like
a and as long as you want kind of i
don't know does steve steve bannon have
an instagram i don't know but he says
here at the end the end paragraph is oh
it's beautiful it's beautiful it's full
of all kinds of trees in here he says
they are coming after all of us i don't
know who us is and i don't know who they
are i'm not really sure i think that bay
is the deep state here
is anyone who believes that there is a
deep state i think that's what he's
saying that's like when trump was like
they gave me the like there's a you know
a good a good clip of uh
of jamie foxx that came out like last
week or two years ago of him doing an
impression but in the end he was like
they gave me the virus you know and he's
like who the [ __ ] is they who is they
who
they actually said that trump actually
said that [ __ ] he goes by the virus and
it's like again who is they right who is
giving you this behind that clip of
jamie foxx i want to believe it but here
here um here steve bannon continues on
says not only president trump and myself
so in other words he's saying you're one
of us
and they're coming after you they which
he probably means the deep state here
because they're talking in code right
their audience they're talking in code i
mean you guys know when i say the cheeto
dust mobster who i'm talking about right
when i say certain things you know so
when he says they his audience knows
he's talking about the the fake deep
state well it's against us
versus them right right you and me i
mean versus them right of course uh i am
never going to stop fighting yeah yeah
when they stick you in a prison yeah
well you won't stop fighting you won't
stop fighting but it might be difficult
right um you know what i'd be curious to
see how steve bannon ends up like what
group he gets associated with and how
long he laughs actually i don't think
anyone would
see him as something to behold in prison
he's got a lot of scabs it looks like
there's a lot of disease there i'm sure
people stay away from but he goes on to
say in fact
in fact gabe in fact
i have not yet begun to fight oh right
remember he said he was going to go
medieval right and he asked he never did
yet he never did so he's admitting that
he didn't go medieval right and he's
then he says
oh my god which oh man
this sentence right here steve bannon
you're after my heart they will have to
kill me first
i i mean this is all [ __ ] this is
all [ __ ] because we watched as he
said he was going to go medieval on
someone he never did anything he never
did a thing
he accepted he accepted the uh
the situation when he was in court why
not [ __ ] it's like oh boy he's such a
[ __ ]
so this is this is the video here of the
yeah this is the video of jamie foxx
okay doing a donald trump impression
this is a recent thing that he's done
it's on it it's on a podcast right is
what they're yeah yeah yeah so he was he
was doing a press tour with snoop dogg
because they have a new movie oh yeah
yeah it's called night shift it's it's
appreciation it's actually it's
hilarious about it yeah i haven't
watched it yet great show you should go
watch it you should go watch it snoop
dogg's great in it jamie is great and
it's a it's a good it's a good movie so
that that's what this is for the um the
press store for the the movie um because
it is snoop dogg and i'm not sure who
the podcasters are but um you see
they're sitting on a couch here and
snoop and true form and the great
clothes that he has only snoop dogg can
pull this stuff off
did you see him at the super bowl the
guy had a sweatsuit on like no one else
could come out at the super bowl and be
such a [ __ ] badass in a sweatsuit he
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
and a lot of people were giving him hell
about it but jamie foxx they go into the
trump impersonation here and jamie gets
close to the microphone and of course is
there anyone and i think that's what you
actually say in the tweet you say is
there anyone jamie cannon personally
brilliant he doesn't
he does quinn tarantino he does robert
downey jr and they're always spot on
they're [ __ ] spot on like that's he's
a talented impressionist and he will get
it down and so yeah again like i don't
know how long it takes him to like get
an impression down but i've seen
numerous interviews where he's like
talking about a conversation he had with
someone and then he goes he can just do
their voice and does their voice well
you know the other thing too about jamie
is he doesn't just do voices he can sing
in those voices too which is even more
incredible yeah which is like just
another you know he's a yeah you know
he's like a quadruple
he's a great talent let's listen to him
do do trump here it's a lot of great
people on both sides lots of great
people
on both sides i know ariel he's a great
person he couldn't vote for me at the
time now he can vote for me once he gets
out i love snoop deal double cheek great
person sure do you love death row
records
excuse me excuse me
and that's the other thing too is excuse
me
jamie just doesn't do the voice like he
can do the mannerisms yeah like he's got
it all
he knows yeah he knows when to go and be
like excuse me
just it's it's perfect he does the other
thing too is like he doesn't because i
know a lot of people who do drop
impressions and they will be like oh
i'll only say fake news or i'll say
i'll say something like that right
they've got a few phrases down right
they do trump really good exactly but
jamie is like just off the cuff well
he's just improvising because they're
asking them questions like oh would you
do this you do this and then as the as
the persona of trump he answers you know
that you know that jamie like when he's
watching clips of trump on tv he's he's
doing him oh yeah you know like that's
how he's practicing let's let's continue
excuse me fake news
[Laughter]
what's your favorite death row record mr
trump all of them
i don't get that throw records don't try
to pin me down
excuse me you excuse me back no fake
news
[Laughter]
they tried to give me the virus
they tried to give me
oh damn
uh they gave me the virus who the [ __ ]
is they i mean really honestly like
that's what you gotta look at his public
statements and be like why
why are we still doing this and that's
the thing they it's all you know it's us
versus them they did it not me i'm the
victim right
and of course this this all seems so
absurd but right jamie foxx even in
comedy and satire and we've talked about
this before is he hits them right on the
head and and really honestly they are
their own they're they are their own
parents i mean even even the mention
that he did at the end where he's like
they were cheering him on like yeah he
beat the vibe right like that's what
he's doing he's projecting it on to the
trump supporters yeah like that's it
when he came back from walter reed and
you know stood up there and had a
difficult time going up the stairs and
was clearly breathing heavy you know and
took off with a mask people were out
there uh outside of the gate like
cheering him on and then the next time
he went to a rally they were like yeah
this is amazing he beat the virus he's
like dude no that is not
why why are you why are you cheering
like no one gave him the virus i mean
in the sense of they
he got the virus from somebody a super
spreader eventually so an actual an
actual they someone gave it to me there
was a person that did give him but
there's no like they the enemy like this
entity of people they
were like
they released the virus so that he
wouldn't be president he called it he
called it this weekend he called it
china dust which again it's like wow
we're really coming back to these like
xenophobic racist remarks
that do no one any good but that's trump
speaking of uh racist the southern
poverty law center and the
anti-defamation league put out a report
which this is i actually don't think
this is news um because we've reported
on it here about the oath keepers having
um not only elected officials but
military members former
former military members law enforcement
officers former law enforcement officers
in their groups um and supporters and
enlistees of the oath keepers um the
group that stewart rhodes and actually
there's more stewart road news he's
actually and i don't know
can you go check scott mcfarland's why
i'm going through this um stewart is
supposed to have a hearing today to
prolong his um is a trial which he will
get the judge is probably going to grant
this motion because he had to retain new
counsel so the new council's gotta have
time to go through all the discovery and
there's just gotta be [ __ ] mountains
of it so the judge is probably gonna
grant him a new trial and i've said this
before on the show it's probably gonna
be sometime next year it won't be in
december that the oath keepers will go
to trial probably next spring or next
summer right because i mean they've also
remember they've got the proud boys as
well so you know those are two kind of
uh uh right same same conspiracy sort of
different cases
and they do cross over so i wouldn't i
would right i wouldn't be surprised if
they are yeah we'll hold off
because we want them to either run at
the same time or build on each other
right well and and the judge the judge
is going to
if a new attorney is
defending stewart the judge is going to
grant him time to go through the
discovery
but this um axios is reporting in here
it's got you know again it's a list of
members and the list of members has
hundreds of law enforcement officials
military members uh elected officials
but we talked about this back in
february with dakota von adams and
tasha adams uh stewart rhodes is a
strange son and estranged wife about how
he would recruit and they told us then
that look he was actively recruiting
active duty police officers
active duty military retired military
retired law enforcement officers and
even elected officials
to give you know some kind of legitimacy
to this group that they weren't just
your normal average white supremacy
para militia group um i mean that's
really was his brand right like when he
was originally doing all this um i mean
that's just what it was and we've had
them on the show several times and again
you can go subscribe to the youtube
channel here now because we've got a
playlist just go to the playlist
there's a playlist with oath keepers
it's got dakota and his mom and several
interviews that we've done with dakota
about the oath keepers about stuart and
news on the prowl boys and the oath
keepers so go check that out go check
those videos out but look
this is not news i mean other than they
verified this list because they have
even said that when stuart first started
to try to gain legitimacy inside of his
group that it wasn't just some kind of
white supremacy group because he was
trying to stay away
from the radar of the anti-defamation
league and the southern poverty law
center and he was actually actively um
they were they were um um scrubbing
members social media accounts to make
sure they weren't saying any racist
things to make sure they weren't saying
any anti-semitic things because he
didn't want people to think that's who
his people were of course
ultimately that's who they were they
just weren't saying in public right but
they also admit that when
closer to trump the the time that trump
came on the scene the harder it was for
stewart to actually recruit so he
started to let down some of those
barriers yeah and he started well yeah
once
you know you you kind of uh remove the
limitation
uh or like what your constraints are to
say like you have to have these
requirements to join
once you start removing those then
obviously you open the floodgates for
the um
uh the recruitment pool right right you
get you know more and more people but as
you get more and more people there's a
little bit of a an unvetted process
that's involved and you get these people
in the military or you get these people
who are white supremacists or affiliated
with this or that and you're finding out
that uh
it's gonna get you in trouble and
yeah again like this is not surprising
to you or i that i mean we know this
right especially when i when i read this
this morning i was like well this isn't
right because i remember when we i mean
we reported on it six months ago if
that's right no one was saying
that's not even the only thing too
because like uh what was in 2020 they
had a report that talked about
the representation of white supremacy
within law enforcement
right well i mean this is a problem
because even even during uh december
2020 when uh trump was calling on the
prowl boys and the oath keepers and the
like to save him you know come to
washington it'll be wild
mark milley the joint chief had to come
out in front of a microphone and say a
couple times hey your oath is to the
constitution and the country not a
person
right so he had to actually warn active
duty military and retired that hey
you took a note to a document not a dude
yeah
like your your constitutional duty is
not to trump
it's to the office and the constitution
that trump is holding and he's not going
to hold it anymore because we had that
thing called an election so you
shouldn't do the thing called treason
and break your oath yeah which that's
the rather reason why he's the this
group is called the oath keepers is
because stewart was actively
um recruiting people who had taken an
oath um and in other words elected
officials law enforcement uh active and
former military people who had would
have taken an oath to the constitution
now because stewart we know he's he's a
veteran and he also is a former lawyer
so he has taken several oaths to a
constitution when he would take those
roles now here's scott mcfarlane as um
the news here about stuart it says alert
court has just scheduled 3 30 p.m this
would be eastern time uh hearing about
11th hour request by oath keepers rhodes
founder
our oath keepers founder stuart rhodes
um to delay his trial in capital ryan
seditious conspiracy case
rose
has just changed defense lawyers trial
is scheduled for september 26th um i'll
be in court at 3 p.m so uh keep track of
this
we'll tweet it out um i definitely will
and i know gabe will as soon as we hear
from scott here because he'll probably
he'll be tweeting from inside the
courtroom as it's happening he usually
does a thread like that especially on a
story like this with stuart rhodes so go
follow scott he's a friend of the show
here and um he keeps us um
up to date with these stories in the
courtroom man he's done a fantastic job
yeah
hands to scott for doing such a
fantastic job of keeping up
um with all the january 6. i don't know
how the [ __ ] he's done it um
he also had i saw when i was looking it
up i saw that he also had an update uh
for enrico who's supposed to have uh
they're gonna retry on monday but i
guess there's some sort of uh error at
the
issue at the jail
um a technical error so they're gonna um
they're gonna bring it back let me see
if i can find that here um
yeah yeah so this is he just tweeted
this 14 minutes ago um so there's a lot
of january 6 news coming down the pike
because these trials are approaching and
we've seen some of them even get
sentenced and we've seen that the
prosecutors are asking for bigger and
bigger sentences as these people get
more and more violent i would imagine
that people like enrique tario
and stuart rhodes if they're found
guilty and convicted in the court
they're probably going to be doing like
dirty 30s where they get like uh 20-year
prison sentences plus 10 years after
on on probation um and that's 30 years
in the federal system uh scott reports
here again technical problem at the jail
um today's virtual court hearing
involving accused january 6th seditious
conspiracy defendant enrique tario has
been postponed till monday they'll try
again so again go follow scott um you
don't want to miss his reporting because
again it's not only a plus reporting but
i have no idea how he keeps up because
honestly gabe like he remembers like
each person and what they did yeah i
mean [ __ ] has to have just a i
don't know if he's got a huge notebook
or if he's had to buy like six terabytes
worth of [ __ ] storage space to know
all this stuff because yeah he's he
tweets the video as like this is the
video that is goes with this defendant
this is the picture that goes with this
one i mean he's he's been doing a
fantastic job so a great service uh to
our country here scott for keeping us uh
up to date in such a public way
for to go for to be able to go
that's why i like twitter it's one of
the best websites out there because you
can go and see this information in real
time uh from actual news journalists
which uh are few and far between anymore
scott's one of the ones that is very i
don't want to say benign what's the good
word because he doesn't really he
doesn't both sides things he doesn't
really give a twist he's just doing the
beat reporting he's giving you i mean he
was just i mean you know independent or
he's neutral right he's just saying like
here is this person and they committed
this crime allegedly or they actually
working you know convicted or charged
but then he just does the reporting on
it so you're like great this is there's
he's not he doesn't take a political
bias he's not right oh i'm i'm only
going to report on this i mean like look
there's no denying that all the people
that he's reporting on are mag
republicans because they did commit
crimes right because they were trying
over to the government so yeah it might
seem a little one-sided but that's not
his fault that's great right well and
that's the other thing too is scott
gives lays out the facts for
commentators like us
right to report this news to you in a
way of why it matters because that's the
most important thing that a lot of these
big news agencies are missing and and
really americans haven't quite
grappled with and understood is there
are news there's facts right that are
reported in journalistic ways like scott
does here and then there's commentary
which is what we do we tell you why
these facts are important why they
affect you because scott really he
doesn't have the well he could if he
wanted to but he doesn't want to
participate in the act of being uh
politicizing a certain issue that's our
job that's our job as commentators to
politicize this stuff that's your job as
a voter that's your job as someone who
wants to engage in your democracy of why
this
these issues and these facts are so
important um again even just a small
fact like enrique tario being postponed
till monday because they have technical
problems at the jail it sounds like a
camera problem or something yeah it's
not they're doing they're doing a remote
right it's remote
but uh back to the stuart rhodes back to
the stuart road story um this is
important because we're not going to see
this trial this month this is going to
be pushed this is going to be kicked
after the election
which regardless of how you want to
believe whether it's good bad for
democracy you are the one who gets to
lean into democracy you are the one who
gets to choose here and knowing the fact
that we are not going to see the trial
of stewart rhodes and the seditious
conspiracy start to take place it is up
to you to politicize this issue it is up
to us as commentators to give you the
facts and lay it out to politicize this
issue because that's where the politics
comes in that's where the elections come
in because there's two things at play
here there's the government
which is the policy whether you're
setting policy or carrying out policy or
oversighting policy and then there's the
election there's the politicization of
it and there's actually winning
elections and that's what you have to do
is the messaging so make sure to stay
tuned here every single weekday so don't
forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel because we broadcast two hours
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and also simulcast on facebook you can
download every single episode on apple
spotify google don't forget to leave us
a review and subscribe on your favorite
directory while you're there very very
important you do not want to miss an
episode also follow us on twitter and
we're coming up on bone end of the week
it's wednesday it's hump day so tomorrow
we're going to put out the bowl for bone
end of the week and boy boy do we
already have a great group of people to
pick from oh [ __ ]
we got bannon we got trump we got all
kind of yeah we got marco rubio oh man
they're going to emerge here so tomorrow
i i have a feeling like today we'll
bring out some other ones right well
tomorrow we got tomorrow morning we got
all day tomorrow that's like six six
months worth of news tomorrow i know so
so stay tuned don't miss a thing
subscribe also if you want to support uh
pro democracy speech you should be doing
that if you want to support this speech
go to
support.tonymicalspot.com or use the qr
code or go to thetonymichaels.com all
those links are down in the description
and you can support pro-democracy speech
and
even if you can't give money you can
like share support share the link tell
your family tell your friends
you know hit that like button subscribe
you know whatever i can do that's right
watch the entire episode download the
entire episode it all it all helps us it
all helps pro-democracy speech it gets
the word out there and all that is
important
so same time same place tomorrow gabe
thursday because tomorrow tomorrow we're
going to be voting on bone end of the
week tomorrow so don't forget to tune in
to see what bone ends we got coming down
the pike so friday we can do bone of the
week because we're here every single
weekday two hours monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central same time same
place tomorrow see you in the super chat
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] him
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking